The Joe Rogan Experience I mean if you
read the Bible it's a pretty interesting
book the first half man when it talks
about the Kings and the one for women
you look at King David there's one for
Bathsheba sent the man to the front
lines to die you know and it's been
throughout history people have been
involved in those kind of situations the
wrong person in your life I actually
think that's what parts of the Bible are
about again I'm not a believer in even
abrahamic religion when I was raised so
I'm trying to take less than what I've
learned a lot of that [__] was just
about bro yeah yeah
gets crazy bro you know what I'm saying
it's crazy that's what their version of
it gets crazy it's crazy bro yeah think
about what you're doing to learn yeah be
careful what you ask for bro you wanted
her bro yeah you know your first child
is going to die with her you know her
you know he's like God damn bro you know
but you get you get you get an amazing
talent kid out of her too you get to
redeem it all but God's Gonna Let You
Feel It a little here how much would you
pay to have been there when they first
started writing that stuff down try to
figure out what did you know where are
you getting these stories I just would
have liked to inject hey man can we keep
can we you know can we make sure Africa
it you know we could talk more about the
black folks you know that's all I would
have just been like yeah yeah like like
bro like come on bro like you know we
were there like not only there you know
you you know Ethiopia Somalia can y'all
like you know all this [__] once was
just Nubia even before it was called
Egypt like like like a lot of this [__]
is based on like what are the Ten
Commandments sound eerily like these
these um these affirmations from Egypt
like what like what you know I would
have um I would have said but you know
man you I gotta just say man to Western
Society
propaganda man y'all have mastered this
[__] whoever the [__] you know what I'm
saying when the church decided yo
blacks and Jewish people man they're
like animals you can enslave them and
Ferdinand and Isabella was like [__] it
let's run this [__] y'all propaganda
campaign been mean man yeah and not
because it
necessarily subjugated people like me to
brute the brutalities of slavery and
[__] like that it convinced poor white
people
that we're good for you
the the one of the most brutal things
about not wanting to know true and
factual history is you don't understand
how you're being [__] over too
it's like if you look at the word
cracker
cracker is not something if black people
made up I used to think you know when
you were young you would hear oh it
means whip cracker you know it wasn't it
was a derogatory term that
um people in the United Kingdom use for
country or slower white folks crackers
and gypsies gypsies were the people
known to populate upper Georgia lower
Tennessee Alabama places like that they
the redneck was also one of the terms we
didn't make these terms but these terms
came from the master class or what they
would call the planner class who used
poor white people and when too many Tim
Wise talked about this when too many
poor white people and black people who
were seen as equals at one point kind of
United and had a few rebellions they
were like no we ought to put the end of
this [__] you know so I would just say
man I wish that whoever was writing the
Bible or remixing it would have put a
little more commonality in there so you
wouldn't get all this weird funky
division in the master still kind of
rule us all you know it's still always
the people that are in charge they're
disseminating that information initially
and they're always they always have some
sort of an intro interest in framing it
in a way that suits them the best like
even in the foundation of the country
all men are created equal yeah so what
they had to do to justify that is to say
that black men are three-fifths of them
so they're literally putting it into the
way they structure the country yeah yeah
and and it was it that was an economic
incentive to do it you know yes and and
that doesn't make it right but it helps
my community understand that the shit's
about money and why they did it but why
did the church do it it's just so you
got to think about that though before we
get to America yeah and I guess the
church the Catholic church at one point
says
we can go ahead and tell everybody all
human beings are equal let's stop
[__] but then they choose to say
Jews and black people are different and
Ferdinand and Isabella and Portugal and
said was well [__] it it's all and you
the transatlantic slave trade starts so
my thing is getting back to why was the
Bible written like that gives back to so
why would the church allow that and then
you get to ask well if the church
allowed that then why aren't they
included in there you know and and
Beyond who's the bad guy what empires in
Africa are we not talking about what
Kings have we not talked about what
great and glorious because the Greeks
looked at Africans like they were Gods
yes they look these [__] these
are the illest [__] on Earth
whoever who was there during the
construction of the pyramids has created
the most insane structures the world's
ever known count Volney says and they
made him retracted but he said of of
ruins of Empires he says it is obvious
to me that the people we now subjugate
to slavery these dark-haired kinky King
kinky hair these dark skin care people
were once the rulers and Builders they
put this [__] here he said that he was
an orientalist which were people who
were sent out of their countries to you
know to go study Asia eastern African
[__] this motherfucker's standing there
like the [__] that built this
[__] somehow we've subjugated slavery
when people say you know if you were
smart enough to do that how could you be
made to slave Genghis Khan wasn't
particularly smart he was violent and
brutal and a lot of times the people who
won have been the most violent and
brutal well Genghis Khan was both but
yeah yeah he was he was both violent
brutal and very intelligent but just
intelligence from a military way yes
tactically no no but that's not Beyond
military like what did he what did he
build
oh there was no building but that's what
I'm saying yeah but it was just figuring
out how to destroy Empire yeah but
that's what I'm saying that's yes that's
not the same though it's building an
empire you get what I'm saying no it's
definitely it's definitely not the same
yeah it doesn't it you know I can I can
I know some gang leaders that that are
comparable to war generals right but the
question becomes who are the people that
are going to build the next Empire right
and I think that that's where the danger
in the old world when the church was
really government the church conspiring
with Warlords for certain things to be
destroyed so they can then come and
assume control though you know because
ultimately even the most brutal people
don't end up winning the most shrewd
people do the the the that small circle
of brilliant [__] that know how
to control like you know beyond Genghis
who who were his advisors who profited
most from it you know what I'm saying
well he was famous for capturing armies
and incorporating their generals yeah
yes he would you know and and if if
someone tried to to surrender he would
just kill them because he would say what
are you going to do with me like why
would I do that oh [__] so they would
say I I've surrendered I've come I'm
coming to you and you go oh really well
I'm gonna [__] kill you because you
have no loyalty people oh [__] oh wow
but he would take over like with certain
generals and certain he would he would
bring them in and just accept them he
was completely open to any religion he
goes I don't give a [__] he was
brilliant for that what your religion he
was brilliant you could be you could be
whatever you want we're here to [__]
people up yeah okay and [__] because
apparently he left a lot of descendants
oh my God yeah they were like one of us
three has Genghis Khan blood in our
bodies apparently it's something crazy
like that we've talked about it many
times and I always forget what the
percentage is